well so we're not talking about Mario
patterns despite the fact that I've worn
you know the worst show ever
um yeah so I'm afraid you're just gonna
have to put up with that this
interesting paper came out a couple of
weeks ago which was doing some rounds on
social media because it's just quite an
interesting concept and the concept is
basically extracting secret keys from
Smart cards and other devices by just
looking at the flickering of LEDs on
their power circuits so in essence you
look at the Led it flickers on and off a
little bit as the power consumption
changes and you can read off the secret
key which is just ridiculous as a
concept right but actually kind of makes
sense when you break it to break down
how it works it does sound a bit
far-fetched which is what's so cool
about it in actual fact
side Channel attacks like this power
analysis and things are actually have
actually been quite common in the past
and so maybe we talk mostly about that
and just in general how they work and
before we talk a bit about the LED thing
I suppose the take-home message really
is apart from it's really interesting is
this is a lot harder to stop than you
think right if you don't think about
this when you implement your
cryptographic algorithm you could have
your LEDs giving away all your secrets
okay so we're gonna put this aside for a
moment and just think about power
analysis we actually did a video on the
Square multiply algorithm if you recall
a little while ago which if I do say to
myself is a great video and you should
definitely definitely watch it but
actually what's something I mentioned in
that video very briefly was the idea
that if you're not careful with your
implementations of algorithms like this
they can be vulnerable to something
called Power analysis or the idea that
you can look at how much power this is
consuming on the CPU or from the power
supply and start to to actually read off
secret bits of key right which doesn't
seem very likely at all but actually if
you're bad of your implementation is
quite straightforward
so if we look very briefly back at how
that worked when you do an RSA digital
signature one of the operations you do
is you take some form of your message
let's call it m or M prime or something
which is maybe like a hash of your
message or a padding of your message and
you're going to raise this number
to the power of your private key right
mod some giant number n now if you
remember when we talked about binary
exponentiation or the square and
multiply algorithm what you would
actually do is you would represent this
D here as binary and then you would do a
series of square or multiply operations
to calculate that sum really really
quickly because otherwise you could
never do it in time
so for example if your current value was
x to the 101 and that's in binary and
you needed to get to 1010 you could
Square this number right so that would
be x to the 101
Times by x to the 101 is equal to x to
the 1010 right very straightforward and
if you wanted to increase it by one you
could do x to the 1010 Times by X is
equal to x to the 1011 right now that's
the whole algorithm I've put a video you
just do a series of these and you can
Converge on whatever this private key is
so what do we do with this as an
attacker well that means that suppose
your your secret key is
[Music]
10110011 now in practice it would be
quite a lot longer than this and suppose
you're in the middle of this algorithm
if you see a zero you're going to need
to do a square if you see a one you need
to First produce the zero then produce
the one so you need to do a square
followed by a multiply which is
essentially two operations so sometimes
you use one operation and sometimes you
use two operations and which of those
you do will depend on if you've got a
zero or a one in your private key that's
a dangerous place to be right because if
you suppose you put some kind of sensor
device on the power supply or you were
looking at the LED and it was reflecting
the amount of power consumption but
let's say the CPU or the cryptographic
chip whatever it was in this system was
doing you might see something like this
so maybe this is your graph or power
analysis power and this is time and you
see it kind of do this and it's using
some power and suddenly it just sort of
spikes up like this and then comes back
down right and then maybe it spikes up
again and comes back down and it spikes
up again and it comes back down
right and what you realize is
that that is a multiply and that is a
square and a multiplied together because
it takes longer right and and you think
well that's actually a bit simple now to
read off the bits because that's one
zero one one you know and even I could
write that code and
it surprisingly difficult to stop these
things and you have to give it real
thought right so what I mentioned in the
previous video was what you might do is
you might do something like the square
always multiplier algorithm or some
variant of this where you're always
doing a square and a multiply even if
it's a zero and that way this happens in
constant time and you don't have this
issue where it goes quicker or slower or
takes more or less power depending on
the bits of the key there are loads of
variants of this including two variants
that are in this paper right so the one
of the ones in the paper is
how long the signature process takes for
an elliptic curve DSA signature can
divulge with enough of these
what the secret key is
because basically it informs us on how
many leading zeros there are in the
random number that was used during
signature right now we're not going to
delve all into that into that attack but
you can get the idea that if you could
measure the power or the time that
things take it could give you some Clues
as to what the secret Keys might be
that in itself is super super
interesting now what this paper has done
which is perhaps even more interesting
is they've managed to do away with the
fact that I've had to sneak in and stick
something on the power cable to work out
what's going on here right that's a
perfectly reasonable attack if I say I
can break your secret key but to do it I
have to get into the server room and
plug something in that's still a huge
problem because that could happen I put
on the hi-vis jacket and I say I've got
a wave sum ID you have a ladder on your
arm have a ladder it makes it look like
I'm fixing the air conditioning or
something and and actually I've got my
little little device
um
you you wouldn't be able to argue that
that was cryptographically Secure
but if you can do this remotely over a
camera on the internet that would be I
would argue even less secure so so
that's where this paper comes is coming
from
so what they've noted is that the
circuitry that controls a power LED on
some of these devices is essentially the
same battery and same circuitry that's
used to do the computation right they're
all on the same kind of circuit and that
means that as the power consumption of
the CPU changes the power going through
the LED also changes and that has in
very very slight but notable differences
in the intensity of these LEDs over time
so you might imagine a situation just
like how I was reading off the power of
a device by putting some specialist
specialist Hardware on it I just look at
an LED and it gets it goes like bright
dim bright dim bright dim like this and
I can start reading off bits or
interpreting that in some way depending
on the algorithm being used that's a
huge problem
um now
one of the issues with this is that you
know these are not slow algorithms right
CPUs are very fast even on smart card
readers and smart cards and that means
that the changes in the LED are going to
be both very very slight but also really
rapid right in the order of you know
nanoseconds milliseconds kind of a kind
of time scale and we don't have cameras
or at least I can't afford a camera that
runs at that kind of frame rate so what
they did in this particular paper was
they used the rolling shutter effect on
a camera to massively increase the frame
rate because all they care about is the
general intensity of the LED not exactly
where it is so imagine a situation where
you've zoomed your camera right into an
LED right either because you've got a
camera with a zoom attached to it or
you've held your phone really close
right now it might be a bit obvious what
you're doing but you know let's let's
let's go with it so your field of view
of your picture has this little giant
whacking LED right in the middle of it
like this right now this led is going up
and down as cryptographic operations are
happening and of course it doesn't match
everything oh we'll come to that it
doesn't no it doesn't matter if it's a
focus if anything it's probably slightly
better if it's not in Focus because it
averages things out nicely
now we won't worry about the edge but
you may be zoom in a bit further when
you get everything in
now this camera let's say on your iPhone
or your your IP based camera that you
managed to hack into right maybe that's
operating at about 60 frames a second or
something like this that is nowhere near
fast enough to capture the kind of
imperceptible changes that are happening
to this led
but the camera isn't actually capturing
an image every 60th of a second right
there are lots of really cool videos
including by smart everyday stand up
maths on rolling shutter effects and the
weird things that happens to propellers
and stuff like this exactly the same
process essentially what happens is the
camera scans down the rows capturing
bits of image as we go right because
that's the easiest way to offload them
so we capture the first row and then the
next row and then the next row and then
the next row and so
across a row that might happen quite
rapidly and between rows
we might see this is now this led got
slightly dimmer when we got to this road
and then slightly brighter again when we
got to this row and we might find that
but basically if you've got a let's say
a 4k camera you're going to increase the
frame rate of your of your system by
about a thousand times well that's even
HD is a thousand yeah enhd so you know
and yes there's going to be some noise
in this system and there's a there's a
there's a slight delay between when you
finish the one frame and you start the
next frame so there are lots of things
you have to calibrate for but it is
practical you point your camera at an
LED and you just video it and then the
fact that these are errors are slightly
different is all you need to be able to
start to do the same kind of power
analysis we were just showing on the
graph right and you haven't had to
install any specialist Hardware you
might have still had to put on on a hat
and pretend you you weren't there but
you know
um so what this attack did was they used
both they use both an iPhone and also a
standard IP camera that they could
control and they zoomed right in on two
different LEDs one of them was was
getting over to slightly less bright and
bearing in mind that these are RGB
cameras so they're producing red green
and blue values between naught and two
five five you might see the average
between these changing by one or two
pixel values right not a lot but enough
that you can see it you know there's
another kind of smart card reader that's
LED changes between blue and red
depending on what it's up to and so you
can start to work out how long it's been
processing for depending on what colors
some of these LEDs are right and so
they're similar attacks different
algorithms different different
cryptographic Protocols are attacking
same kind of principle
so I find this really really interesting
because you know you think there's no
way I've made my smart card reader I've
used special algorithms or whatever no
one's no one's getting into this it's
tamper-proof all this kind of business
and you realize that your LED is just
divulging your uh your secret key and
that's not what you want so in the paper
they attack two different algorithms one
is elliptic curve DSA which is used for
digital signatures very common in
digital certificates
um another is uh s-i-k-e or super
singular
um isogeny elliptic curve key exchange
or something like that something like
that right which has its own problems
actually is now with many way but it's
one of these Quantum resistant
algorithms or at least it was until
recently uh so
um two different algorithms basically
same kind of problem it's it doesn't in
a way I think it's quite interesting how
common these kind of problems are
cross-implementations across different
algorithms when you're doing computation
based on a secret you better be sure
that that computation is extremely
consistent because otherwise you're
going to divulge what that secret is
which is you know really really
interesting
that is a bad shirt for filming but is
it going to be I'm not going to make you
take it off but look at the Moira can
you see on there I know do you think we
can I I thought about it and I thought
maybe we sort it out like by zooming in
or something or it all comes down to
what some whatever resolution it ends up
as and whatever so there's not a lot we
can do it